as market surged after Trump shreds
NAFTA we have to ask ourselves is it
possible that the smart people are
stupid and the stupid people are smart
then speaking of dopes one in seven
Americans smokes pot we will analyze the
growing popularity of Haitian oregano in
the u.s. left-wing shill Lanny Davis
admits that admitted liar Michael Cohen
is a liar CNN pays no heed
then more demagoguery of dead people
hashtag me to Hollywood hypocrites why
everybody is suddenly transgender and
bad parents I'm Michael Knowles and this
is the Michael Noel's show
[Music]
we've got a lot to get to today as you
can tell and oh oh this this whole thing
for those of you who are not listening
you might be confused I'm wearing an
American flag bow tie right now that is
of course because it is national bowtie
day I could not let that day pass
unheeded this brings up a long-standing
debate among American conservatives is
it super cool to wear the American flag
is clothing or is it disrespectful to
the flag every this always happens you
wear like Chubby's has those little
shorts you know the swim trunks and they
look like an American flag and then some
conservatives say that's disrespectful
and then others say it's awesome it's
awesome it's great where where the
American flag the reason you should do
it this isn't true at all times in
history and in all cultures but our
culture is so anti-american right now
anyway that you can get the flag out
there that's good do it where it's great
there's another debate of course over
bowties which is our bowties you know
like American conservative mid-century
cool or do they always look terrible
there is there's just no acceptable time
to wear them you know which side of that
argument that I come down on but I'd be
interested to hear your thoughts in the
comments so we've got to talk about
dopes today we've got a lot of dopes in
America we've got stupid smart people
smart stupid people and everybody is
getting high there's a new study out
that shows that one in seven Americans
smokes pot in his smoke pot within the
last year for comment on this we turn to
daily wire pot correspondents Cheech and
Chong
we're pretty interesting yeah I I would
have to agree that is some heavy stuff
man that's some heavy stuff one in seven
Americans the question is who cares if
we're smoking pot this is this perennial
debate among not just the left and the
right but within the right between the
libertarians and the conservatives hey
let's just legalize it and this issue
this issue of legal pot is one of the
great examples of conservatives throwing
their hands up and saying oh who cares I
don't want to fight anymore that's okay
blah blah blah I am gonna make the point
that perhaps we shouldn't be gung-ho
about legalizing pot and there are a few
reasons for this one right now in
America one in five people live in a
state with legal pot because lefty
states with big populations are more
likely to have legalized pot the pot
industry is pretty big the pot into the
legal pot industry was almost six
billion dollars last year I have no idea
how big the illegal pot industry which
is still still accounts for the majority
of it in America 50% of people have
tried pot at least once the majority at
least 50% the majority of Americans have
tried pot at least once judging by my
outfit today as you can guess I too have
tried the old Haitian oregano once or a
few times and so I'm not saying that I
haven't done it a lot of people have
done it and it leads to bizarre results
and much as you're looking at right here
11% of Americans are regular users of
pot so the and and one-in-seven have had
it within the last year they might not
be regular users they might not be
waking and baking or smoking every night
or something but they have it every so
often you know once you cut twice a year
and that number is way way up that
number has doubled within either the
last decade or the last few decades it
breaks down by sex so for women the
number has doubled since 1984 for men
the number has doubled since of around
the year 2000 but the numbers are way
way up what does this mean obviously pot
is being mainstreamed why is it being
mainstreamed it's being mainstreamed by
the culture and it's being mainstreamed
by the government a lot of states are
pushing for legalization a lot of states
have legalized medical marijuana a lot
of states have legalized recreational
marijuana in my own town of la-la-land
Holly
but there were giant billboards on the
street that say get we'd delivered to
your door come on it's really use a nap
and you get pot delivered to your door
the the debate around pot is very very
stupid I'm not saying that there aren't
good points on both sides I'm saying
that the debate is always extremely
stupid because it usually goes something
like this well man you know man pot is
way better for you than better than
booze because booze gets you angry man a
pipe just mellows you out
yeah and it's totally not addictive and
it's and it really expands your mind you
know like what if the color you see is
red I see is blue you know man it just
makes you so smart doesn't make you
smart
it makes you stupider and less funny and
and the trend one of the really awful
things about pot and I can tell you this
from experience it's not like I've never
smoked pot before is that you think you
think when you're a smoking pot that
you're smarter and funnier but you're
not you just think that because you have
become stupider I remember you know in
I'll give examples of this because when
I say that I've smoked pot on more than
one occasion and I did inhale like it's
actually very hard for me to inhale
though cuz I smoke cigars and I've
smoked cigars since I was a kid so when
I tried to smoke pot which was much
later I couldn't do it like I just I
still would coffee you know dramatically
even I can't have a cigarette you know
for that reason but in I think it was
chef on South Park who says that there
is a time and a place for everything in
that place is college so there is this
thing at Yale which is Spring Fling and
every every year on Spring Fling you
know they bring bands in and you know
it's a big party every year the they
treat pot brownies like it's a sacrament
you know like it's just very popular at
least it was when I was there and so I
would try this and this put to rest a
lot of my thoughts on pot because we're
always told oh it's not very potent it's
not it doesn't it's not dangerous it's
not whatever like that is total nonsense
that is total nonsense first of all it
is addictive there are new studies out
that show that it is quite addictive it
can be addictive but in between 11 and
17 percent of users and also
it can be very very potent it actually
can put you at risk especially when you
ingest it so when you ingest unlike you
know you smoke a joint or something if
you ingest pot depending on the
concentrations of THC which now are sold
at your local dispensary in Los Angeles
you can really mess you up you get your
heart rate gets much much faster you get
totally disoriented it'll eat you can
lead to death of brain cells it can lead
to memory loss especially if you do it
when you're young especially if you do
it over time so what does this have to
do with the policy debate which is
should we legalize pot shouldn't we
legalize pot obviously more Americans
are using pot today than they did even a
decade ago dramatically more this is
coinciding with the laws being
liberalized I think you have to look at
it from the social perspective it from a
broader social context not just some
stupid libertarian talking point of well
you the government doesn't have a right
to tell you what the government tells
you a lot of things to do or well it
doesn't hurt anybody well it hurts you
well it does hurt the guy that you run
over in a car when you're driving higher
it can hurt people but look at our
particular point in time right now
Americans are killing themselves they're
killing themselves in record numbers
with booze with drugs and with and and
with weapons they're committing suicide
at very high rates right now in the
United States self-injury is self-injury
is the seventh leading cause of death
it's more deadly than diabetes at this
point and what the libertarians say here
is well the government shouldn't
intervene but the legalization of
marijuana is the government intervening
this is why the pot alcohol thing is so
stupid
alcohol has been around our culture
since the dawn of time we you know Jesus
Christ his first miracle on earth after
the Incarnation was to make really good
wine for drunk people for people who
were already very drunk he made wine for
them that booze has been around forever
it's going to be around forever this is
not an argument for booze but it's it's
making a non ideological point for
conservatism which is that we are we
don't just pop out of nowhere we don't
come into the world in floating in the
air without any context we come within a
social and historical context and that
social and historical context has boozin
it for better or worse rates of drinking
have decreased dramatically since the
19th century say but it's just around us
we're not gonna get rid of it it I don't
think we really would want to get rid of
it entirely
there's probably a reason it's stuck
around so long the question is why would
you want to introduce a new drug because
in the West pot doesn't come from our
tradition it hasn't been around for
2,000 years Jesus didn't perform the
miracle of I don't know turning oregano
into marijuana that's that's not in our
culture that's not in our history so why
would you want to introduce a new one
all of the arguments that the pro pot
people say against alcohol or also
arguments for not legalizing marijuana
by saying that one is better than the
other it's not saying that they're good
right they're both bad for you there's a
lot of tar in marijuana it's bad for
your health it makes you stupid or it
makes you you know it also one thing
about alcohol is it's a social lubricant
so if you go like this is one of the
reasons why it's persisted in culture
for so long is you know just unless
you're very depressing you don't just
sit in your room alone and guzzle
whiskey you know you I mean I I do it
for breakfast obviously but that's just
to get ready for to meet you for my show
I have nice and nice a short stack of
pancakes and a gallon of
room-temperature gin but you know it's a
social lubricant it kind of amps you up
a little bit you get to talk to people
whereas pot is very much its best in
solitude because it makes you stupid and
because it makes you less funny
it really just they they always say well
it really makes you think it really
makes you expands your mind right it
doesn't do that but it's a drug for
solitude so if we've got this problem
we've got this major drug problem as
major opioid epidemic these these people
killing themselves with stimulants and
drugs and whatever why would we allow a
new one to be introduced the government
the government just like us doesn't come
from nowhere it's not just floating it
comes from a historical context right
now pot is broadly illegal if pot is
legalized that is not the lack of
government intervention that
specifically is government intervention
to legalize that why would we want to do
it last year alone seventy-two thousand
people died from drug overdoses in the
United States this is a record number
and 28
teen is already on track to blow past
that number why would you want to do it
you know this is a big mistake of
libertarianism I noticed this whenever
conservatives give up an issue they
always say well now I'm a libertarian on
this issue but it's only after they lose
the issue though now I'm a libertarian
so they do this sometimes for that for
those who became pro-choice in favor of
abortion during the the height of
abortion advocacy you know the 1990s
it's really pro-choice they would say oh
well I'm a libertarian I'm a lipid
there's nothing libertarian about
killing a baby there's nothing in the
libertarian ideology or doctrine that
says you have to be able to kill babies
of course not
libertarianism protects a life liberty
and property life comes first not not
liberty the same thing they did this on
gay marriage they'll say the
conservatives who'd said marriage has a
definition and sexual difference in
hears in marriage sexual difference has
something to do in marriage and that's
why it's not that gay people can't get
married
it's that marriage does not involve a
marriage demand sexual difference now
that the left seems to have won that
battle at the Supreme Court in the
culture they say oh I'm a libertarian
there's nothing libertarian about saying
we have to adopt this very radical new
definition of marriage but not previous
definitions and not other definitions
there's nothing libertarian about saying
that marriage has to now be defined as a
union of two people regardless of sex
who love each other for whatever purpose
you want rather than the previous
definition which is it's the union of
husbands and wives for family or some
other definition why doesn't why isn't
it libertarian to say that marriage
involves the polygamous union of
same-sex people why is that isn't isn't
that libertarian why don't we have that
no it's just a total cop-out and they do
this with drugs they say well when it
comes to drugs I'm a libertarian this is
this presents a very mistaken view of
virtues and of the tradition that we
come out of and a political philosophy
drugs enslave you I'm not I'm not saying
that you can't have little you know a
glass of wine and moderations of whiskey
and moderation even a smoke of pot in
moderation I'm saying that when you
become addicted
when you use drugs excessively when you
abuse drugs they enslave you you're
giving in to your appetite you're not
you're not living rationally you're not
living consciously you're not living in
freedom
there's nothing libertarian about that
that's that's libertine not libertarian
and it's a it's a big mistake
conservatives shouldn't give this one up
they shouldn't give up anything they
shouldn't be bullied and be intimidated
by the left to give up points and
needlessly and then pretend that that's
libertarianism that creates a nation of
dopes and this point was underscored
beautifully by President Trump just this
past week because what were we told
during the election Trump is gonna be
terrible for the economy and if he if he
gets rid of NAFTA the North American
Free Trade Agreement the agreement
between Canada the United States of
Mexico the economy is gonna implode it
through the awful prices are gonna rise
where it's gonna be awful from Mexico
for Canada especially for the United
States so President Trump
rips up NAFTA he creates a bilateral
trade agreement with Mexico and says
remember Mexico we were never going to
be able to deal with Mexico now we've
got a great relationship with Mexico all
the smart people told us it would be
terrible we have a great relationship
with Mexico and the president from says
Canada is more than welcome to come in
but if they're not going to agree to our
terms they can stay out what happened
when this was announced NAFTA ripped up
bilateral trade deal all the smarts that
predicted it instead of the economy
crashing the markets reach record highs
record highs the S&P 500 was up almost
one percent yesterday Nasdaq was up
almost one percent yesterday
the Nasdaq broke eight thousand I think
that's an all-time record the Dow jumped
259 points all the way up this was the
first time yesterday that the Dow was
above 26,000 since February the markets
universally responded well to this news
about NAFTA we also found out today that
consumer confidence is at an 18-year
high but remember this you've got to
remember this because it always gets
blown over in the media nobody ever
talks about this in the mainstream media
so you just forget that these things
happen you forget when these pundits
when the smart set when the the
self-appointed betters and sophisticates
and self-styled smart people when they
predict things they get it totally wrong
and then they get to go right on making
predictions here is thus just just to
refresh your memory here is a little
prediction from the self-appointed smart
set the stupid smart people of what was
going to happen to the economy if
President Trump was elected are you
saying that if Trump wins and I do too
after that the markets are going down
fifteen percent ten percent I think ten
percent at May actually if it looks like
he's close it may drift a little before
but the net effect will be about ten
percent he has no real strategy for
creating jobs just a string of empty
promises and maybe we shouldn't expect
better from someone whose most famous
words are you're fired
Donald Trump offers no real solutions
for the economic challenges we face I
have my Trump hedge on in the event
Donald wins I have no doubt in my mind
the the market tanks Donald Trump's
ideas about the economy and the world
will cause millions of Americans to lose
their jobs and what happened what what
can we ask what happened let's let's
because these guys say Hillary Clinton
who is that Mark Cuban the billionaire
who just goes runs his mouth on TV all
these predictors don't lose sight of
what they're saying they're saying
millions of jobs will be lost the
economy will tank they're making actual
predictions none of which happened and
yet we still look to them they're the
smart people they're the stable people
Hillary Clinton she's stable she's the
stable she's the reasonable choice Oh
pish-posh we can't vote for Trump he's
crazy
Hillary she's stable she's she's stable
wrong she's very in a very stable way
she's wrong her predictions did not come
true
here is what actually happened
confidence is the highest it's been in
many years just came out manufacturing
the highest level of confidence they've
had since they started doing it many
years ago and business it has the
highest level of confidence I was
president Trump in the Cabinet Room
earlier today he also pointed out which
he likes to do but it's a fact look at
the chart Dow's up more than 5,000
points in one years never done that
for 70 new highs for the Dow Jones
Industrials remember when everyone said
the market was just gonna tank the day
after the election and fall through the
floor didn't happen historic tax reform
on top of that 3% GDP growth and a
forecast to potentially do 4% in the
third quarter we'll see if that happens
moments ago the numbers for America's
economic growth or GDP were just
released and I am thrilled to announce
that in the second quarter of this year
the United States economy grew at the
amazing rate of 4.1% we're on track to
hit the highest annual average growth
rate in over 13 years and I will say
this right down I'll say it strongly as
the trade deals come in one by one we're
going to go a lot higher than these
numbers and these are great numbers
during each of the two previous
administrations we averaged just over
1.8 percent GDP growth by contrast we
are now on track to hit an average GDP
annual growth of over 3% and it could be
substantially over 3% remember those
images
remember those two clips that you just
saw because I think sometimes sometimes
I get accused of being a little too
favorable to President Trump to
president khofifah sometimes people
think I'm flagging for him or something
like that I don't know why they would
ever think that fix my American flag bow
tie I think I get accused of that I
think that's totally unfair because what
I'd like to point out are those two
clips all of this all of the smart
people all of the serious sophisticated
you know they're stable leaders all of
those people
we're totally wrong they have been
totally wrong in their predictions and
Donald Trump who is regularly pilloried
as an absolute idiot not just by people
on the left but also by people on the
right by a lot of people on the right
hilary him is an idiot and incompetent
political newbie dummy doesn't know what
he's doing
that guy that person who has been pill
on the left on the right as an idiot has
been right about almost everything he's
been right about virtually everything
did the numbers don't lie
we're just talking about the economy
right now this extends in many many ways
so I just want you to remember that when
when you see someone and say oh he's
being too favorable to President Trump
President Trump has been right about
virtually all of these things and it all
the smart said on the left and the right
have been wrong they have been wrong
since the beginning this should cause us
to maybe take a step back and have a
little a moment of reflection here this
is true not just on the economy another
great example of the smart set actually
probably the perfect example is a global
warming climate change the Paris Accord
remember the Paris Accord if we didn't
sign on to the Paris Accord where all
the nations are gonna get together and
hug each other and that's for some
reason that's going to be really good
for the environment if if that doesn't
happen the world will implode that's
what we were told we were told that even
by some people on the right but but
certainly by the entire left and the
president Trump said I'm not gonna sign
on to that Paris Accord he was utterly
pilloried for it here's just one example
President Trump
announcing that he's gonna pull out of
the Accord and a little example of how
the Left reacted the rest of the world
applauded when we signed the Paris
agreement they went wild
they were so happy for the simple reason
that it put our country the United
States of America which we all love at a
very very big economic disadvantage what
are you talking about they were happy
because they secured a landmark victory
for the future of the planet you've been
a go maniac
firing against the United States so just
keep that in mind keep that you effing
maniac what are you doing yeah yeah
right right
Trump's the idiot and John Oliver
representing the entire left in the
anti-trump right he's the he's the smart
guys are you so are you an idiot are you
effing kidding me
well it turns out Trump was entirely
right and that guy was entirely wrong we
have new numbers that have come out
which shows that the United States is
leading the world in reducing carbon
dioxide emissions the United States
which pulled out of the Paris agreement
which said go pound sand an
international community you're trying to
entrap us in an agreement that forces us
to give up some of our freedom that
forces us to play by unfair rules that
gives an international advantage to
other people you're not serious about
helping the environment we are serious
we're going to do it on our own
that's what President Trump said
pilloried by dum-dums like John Oliver
and everybody else mocked laughed by
frivolous as frivolous audiences on HBO
and then what happened the United States
is leading the world in reducing co2
emissions and the signatories to the
Paris Accord are not only not keeping
their promises they are increasing their
co2 emissions which means that they
weren't serious about the Paris Accord
it means they didn't want to help the
environment they weren't getting ready
for this landmark international kumbaya
moment they just wanted to entrap the
United States in an agreement that they
would not play fairly by means that
Donald Trump was entirely right about
this and the left and John Oliver in
particular were completely wrong Canada
Spain the European Union and China all
increased their co2 emissions since that
Paris agreement all of them we were told
this agreement this is Seoul and Markey
is India and China are finally gonna
play along well they didn't we now know
that they didn't and that guy that the
stupid guy the stupid orange/mango
Mussolini what an idiot he doesn't know
anything about anything was completely
right about this and all of the really
smart people with glasses were
completely wrong imagine just imagine
that Hillary Clinton had won my third
cousin once removed just imagine that
for a second I haven't watched a clip of
Hillary in a while and I just watched
her you know seeing it on the show right
now imagine that imagine how
awful that would be because she was the
responsible choice all of my friends who
have lots of degrees you know they have
PhDs and master's degrees and law
degrees and doctors and all do to do to
do all of them they were horrified that
I voted for Donald Trump horrified they
say you can't that's irresponsible
that's your risk but he's not competent
he's not smart he's reckless he's that
guy's been totally right Hiler all of
Hillary's predictions were not and not
only have not come true but the opposite
has actually come true and then we got
news today that her email server the
competent Hillary expert Hillary stable
Hillary that her email server that we
already know has been hacked by bad
actors was also hacked by the Chinese
that information came out today her
email server was hacked by the Chinese
they installed a code such that her
emails emails that were going to her
from her were being sent to these to
this Chinese entity in real time that's
stable Hillary that's the smart person I
don't have Donald Trump's emails been
hacked by multiple foreign adversaries
has that happened yet maybe it'll happen
I don't that hasn't happened yet I
haven't seen that that big that big
dummy who doesn't know anything he's
managed to avoid that but all the smart
people like Hillary Clinton then they
get their emails hacked by multiple
major foreign adversaries unbelievable
and and then the story gets better it
gets like a if someone wrote this movie
and then pitched it to a Hollywood
studio the studio would say no it's too
on-the-nose that's too obvious that's
too you couldn't do it this the the hack
by China was reported to the FBI
multiple times and the FBI did nothing
about it and and who was it at the FBI
who did nothing about it Peter struck
ladies and gentlemen that loverboy
disgraced the FBI agent who testified
before Congress and looked like the
devil incarnate you know that maniacal
face and smile and horns spreading out
of his head Peter struck it was that guy
and the reason that this would be
rejected if it were a Hollywood pitch is
that it's like I thought there were more
FBI agents than that how come this guy
he keeps popping up you think are there
hold on a second all right there they're
more than like five people that work at
the FBI right but this guy Peter struck
seems to always crop up at the center of
corruption at all times the emails with
his lover girl trying to nail Trump
investigating Trump based on faulty
paid-for Democrat hack dossiers then
he's on a Muller investigation trying to
get Trump again he actually gets fired
for that reason and he's the one who
won't report that Hillary has been
incompetently handling her emails
unbelievable you know all of this should
serve as a warning then I've got a say
goodbye to Facebook and YouTube all of
this I bring up to you all the way from
the pot and those dope heads to the dope
heads on CNN and HBO the left always
tries to intimidate us and I'll even go
more broadly than the left the left and
the preening anti Trump right always try
to intimidate us by making conservative
people think we're stupid they try to
they try to make us think that we're
stupid they said we're really smart look
we were tweed we have tweed jackets go
we have bowties we have special glasses
you know we go we sip Shelley you don't
even know what Shelley is we sip Shelley
we know we're the competent ones were
the stable ones you can't vote for Trump
he's an idiot he's a fool he's a dummies
doesn't know what he's doing he's a bla
bla bla bla bla just remember that in a
broad array of issues over just the last
year or two years that self-appointed
smart set has been utterly wrong have
been made to look like total fools and
the stupid people the hacks the
partisans the Trump apologists the
lackeys the Magha
crowd the blah blah blah have been
correct about everything just keep that
in mind I'd like people to remember that
because I think sometimes this gets
forgotten and and we'll get to why that
gets forgotten it's because the new not
only or the news media stacked against
us but everything around the news media
are stacked against us this has just
come out in the last day before we get
to that I've got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube donut this is very
frustrating because we've got so much
more to talk about but we'll talk about
it once we see you at the Le wire comm
if you're at Daily wire comm thank you
very much you helped keep the lights on
you keep khofifah in my cup you keep me
in silly bowties and
we jackets if you're not there if you're
on Facebook and YouTube you won't be for
long cuz they're going to censor us so
go over to daily wire it's ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership what
do you get you get me you get the Enric
Laban show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get to ask questions in the mailbag
that's coming up Thursday you test
questions in the conversation that's
gonna be the big boss Ben Shapiro coming
up very soon none of that matters here
it is here mmm-hmm was this brew was
this imported from Mexico or from Canada
with this made right here in the United
States I don't know but this is the
NAFTA brew this is the NAFTA brew and it
and it tastes like yeah it tastes like
the Nasdaq hitting 8,000 that's what it
tastes like it tastes like the S&P
hitting records and it tastes like mmm
yeah I'm getting a slight hint on the
top of the palate of the Dow Jones
breaking 26,000 for the first time since
February I'm getting justyou can kind of
get it a little hint on the nose go to
Daly wire.com we'll be right back we had
a lot more to talk about
so why do we always forget that the
smart people are stupid and the stupid
people are smart the reason is that the
news media are not only totally turned
against conservatives and the Trump
administration but everything around the
news media are as well there's a new
piece out
it's a PJ Media I suggest you go read it
by Paula bully yard that shows she just
searched Trump in Google News Google
News major news source I check it
constantly and just search Trump
ninety-six percent of the results even
for her who is a conservative you would
think they might be more tailored to
skew conservative for her ninety six
percent of the results were from
left-wing news sources ninety-six
percent of them the only wire doesn't
seem to crop up does it
but voxcom certainly does 96 percent and
the sources by the way are liars we have
this story out today CNN ran a story
about how Donald Trump knew about
Russian collusion and knew of the Russia
meeting at Trump Tower and knew about
all of this knew about all of this the
source for those stories was Lanny Davis
the left-wing hacky attorney for Michael
Cohen so the source really is Michael
Cohen through that just within the last
day Lanie Davis has come out and said oh
yeah I was just kidding do I was just
kidding I don't I can't say I don't know
that Donald Trump knew ahead of time
about the Russian meeting oh I don't I
can't say I don't what do I know I don't
know but last week he was saying Bob
Muller should talk to Michael Cohen
we've got damaging information on Trump
and Russia we're we he's got a lot that
he should hear and now he's completely
changed his tune
so Lanny Davis was the source for this
story was reported everywhere after it
made it to CNN and all the confirming
sources were Lanny Davis turnouts turns
out it wasn't true Lanny Davis himself
is saying yeah I lied and who knows if
he lied her if Michael Cohen lied I
don't know but what I do know is CNN
won't retract the story some people are
noticing that CNN worded their story in
such a way that they can probably get
away with it because it's just
extraordinarily misleading but it's it's
a dishonest I mean these are people who
are lying by omission or misleading in
such a way that it's a lie the media
Research Center is also showing the
extent of Big Tex censoring us because
you hear it from us look we see our
views fluctuate very wildly depending on
changes in these social media algorithms
and depending on what who they're
censoring that week but these are just
little anecdotes the media Research
Center went in and went past the
insinuation to get to some specifics we
know that Twitter specifically with
shadow banning people whose profiles
used the words America or God because
they thought they were robots can you
imagine for a second if you just a met
just pity the Twitter executives here
let's not ascribe it to malice let's
describe a district they think they're
in such an anti-american bubble they're
in such an absurd left-wing bubble that
they think that if you use the words
America or God you can't be a human
being you have to be a robot and their
shadow banning people for that they also
won't run ads for pro-life advocacy
groups they will run ads for Planned
Parenthood that's one specific area we
know that they put specific care behind
the trending hashtags Podesta emails and
DNC leaked during the election they
suppress that they shadow banned those
hashtags even though they were they were
clearly making the rounds among popular
users on Facebook Facebook shadow banned
or suppress trending stories from Mitt
Romney's CPAC and Rand Paul on the flip
side when black lives matter was not
trending Facebook bumped that up and
made it trending news to spread the
message of black lives matter that's
another specific it's not just the news
- it's not just these platforms that's
not just Google News Google search also
is favoring Democrats so when you search
for any of these things not in news but
in the regular google.com you're gonna
get a slew of left-wing articles over
right-wing articles is it any wonder
that we think this that the stupid smart
people are smart and the smart stupid
people are stupid it's because all of
the curation around our information is
tailored to give us that false
impression why else we know that YouTube
is censoring videos we know that Google
YouTube and Twitter are partnering with
far-left organizations the Southern
Poverty Law Center I have a great honor
because it said that my Prager you video
is the most egregious one
that's a great I want like a I want to
frame that statement and make it a prize
we know that Twitter's advisers on
content or twelve to one skew leftist
twelve to one and we know that they
partner with these fact checkers which
are far far left-wing Facebook partners
with Snopes the fact checker Snopes
Snopes flagged the babylon be an
obviously satirical publication for
criticizing CN n flagged it on facebook
and it went through outrageous we don't
have a ton of time but i want to call
your attention to that because when
you're using google when you're using
google news you have to be aware that
there is a very intentional narrative
being built around you there is a force
at work that is trying to convince you
that the smart people are stupid and the
stupid people are smart and that's why
you think that it's why it's a prejudice
in public discourse is because people
sitting at these companies are creating
it for you speaking of fact checks
speaking of fact checks we do need to
fact check the media and the means here
we have to get to some more demagoguery
of dead people i've tried to avoid
talking about john mccain or Molly
Tibbets too much to people who have died
recently who have become major news
stories obviously and who have been
injected into public debate i don't
really blame people for injecting them
into public debate first of all john
mccain is a public figure so that goes
for that saying and that molly Tibbets
news story was a major national news
story before politics got involved at
all so i'm not really blaming people but
right now there is a debate going on
because molly Tibbets was killed by an
illegal alien the left is so upset with
this that they're trying to pretend that
he wasn't an illegal alien but he was an
illegal alien all of the evidence we
have at our disposal says he was an
illegal alien and this is the in an
obvious point for conservatives who say
if if we enforce our laws that guy
wouldn't have been in the country simple
as that we enforce our laws that guy
wouldn't have been in the country that's
not to say that illegal aliens murder
more people than native-born people do
that's not to say that illegal aliens
murder more people than other immigrant
groups like legal immigrant groups do
it's not to say any of those things it's
just to say very simply that person
wasn't supposed to be in the country it
was a failure of law enforcement and
really a failure of politics
in the country and that what that girl
would be alive today if he wasn't in the
country if we enforced our border laws
that's a simple observation now the left
is doubling down they're saying how dare
you this is awful and there's a
statement that's floating around that is
people are purporting is from the
Tibbets family writ large or that it's
from Mali tippins's mother it's actually
from a woman named Sandy Tibbets Murphy
and Sandy Tibbets Murphy is not Mali
tippins's mother even though that has
been reported in various social media
platforms that isn't the case she's a
cousin of Mali Tibbets and she sent at
this statement that was very left-wing
excoriated the GOP I just I just want to
read this too to show you how ridiculous
it is I'm not really I'm criticizing her
statement I'm not criticizing her
because she's grieving a family member
has died but we have to correct the
record because you can't let this kind
of actual fake news fester sandy Tibbets
Murphy sent out this statement it reads
this whoa no no no no especially for
those of you who did not know her in
life you do not get to usurp Molly and
her legacy for your racist false
narrative now that she is no longer with
us
molly was killed and a man has been
arrested and charged with her murder yes
that man is an immigrant to this country
he's not an immigrant he's an illegal
alien but I go on with uncertainty as to
his legal status it's not really
uncertain all of the evidence says he's
the illegal I go on but it matters not
he could have been a citizen born in
this country he could have been an older
white man from anywhere he could have
been a man from Molly's world I'll go on
and then we can discuss this because the
the political propaganda in this
statement is very frustrating she goes
on he is a man whose path in life
crossed that of Molly's life with tragic
results he is a man who felt entitled to
impose himself on Molly's life without
consequences he's a man who because of
his sense of male entitlement refused to
allow Molly the right to reject his
advances the right to her own autonomy
molly was murdered because a man denied
her right to say so our national
discussion needs to be about violence
committed in society mostly by men it is
not your right to exacerbate this
grievous act by hijacking Molly and all
she believed with your racist
fear-mongering you do not get to use her
murder to inaccurately promote your
permanently separated hyperbole
you do not have permission to callously
use this tragedy to demonize an entire
population for the acts of one man no we
reclaim our Mali respectfully
respectfully sandy Tibbets Murphy you do
not have the right to use this murder to
push your sexist propaganda just that
you're saying that we don't we don't
have the right to push him and
ostensibly racist propaganda you don't
have the right to push the sexist
propaganda look at this she said it's
not because he was an illegal alien it's
cuz he's a man again I'm not crime not
really criticizing this girl I don't
know this girl she's probably very much
in mourning because her cousin is dead
but we have to correct this record
because what she's saying is don't blame
you legal aliens blame all men how is
that how is that fixing the painting
with a broad brush you're saying we're
painting a small group with a broad
brush you're painting a gigantic group
with a broad brush that isn't true she
says well it could have been a different
man it could have been a white guy could
have been a middle-aged guy right but it
wasn't it wasn't any of those things he
was an illegal alien the reality all of
the probabilities collapse into this
reality and that's the reality that we
have to deal with she says that we
shouldn't push the permanently separated
hyperbole that's not hyperbole Molly
Timmons has been permanently separated
from her family we shouldn't have to
tell a member of her family that I'm
very sorry for those who are grieving
that isn't hyperbole that's a real
that's a real fact and we have to deal
in facts we have to deal in reality and
not deal with a bunch of fake news and
political propaganda if if people aren't
going to if the family doesn't want this
to be politicized I totally understand
that but then one should not be
politicizing it on the other side as
well we're running so late as usual so I
do want to get to two louis c.k and
Michael Ian Black speaking of toxic
masculinity Torrey was a toxic
masculinity louis c.k you remember this
remember when louis c.k exposed himself
to a bunch of women and co-workers and
people now he showed up recently in a
comedy club and he started performing
people were surprised you know someone
complained and said I didn't know he was
going to be here this is nine months
after five women co-workers you know
accused him of assaulting them so
Michael in black Lefty par XL
he comes out and he tweets this quote
will take heat for this but people have
to be allowed to serve their time and
move on with their lives I don't know if
it's been long enough or his career will
recover or if people will have him back
but I'm happy to see him try ok so
Michael Ian Black is the guy who
previously tweeted quote this is right
after Trump was elected tonight I
explained sexual assault to my 13 year
old daughter hashtag Magga okay he also
tweeted at Ted Cruz he said hi Ted Cruz
this was when the race was going on in
Alabama for the Senate hi Ted Cruz just
wondering if you've seen the latest
allegation of sexual assault of a 16
year old by Roy Moore and if you still
endorse his candidacy
so that's Michael Ian Black and now he's
coming around when it's one of his when
it was a Republican who's been accused
of sexual crimes then he's on his high
horse he's sanctimonious when it's a
friend of his all of a sudden we need a
little grace we need a little mercy we
need to let people have you know come on
man let them recover this is total
hackery and it brings up this point that
we've talked about a little earlier with
the dupes I think sometimes people think
that I'm advocating too much for Donald
Trump right play favorites or something
like that and that isn't the case I'm
not being partisan here I'm just being
honest and these people are not being
honest people like Michael Ian Black
self-serious on his high horse
sanctimonious until it's his friend and
then all of a sudden it's completely
different because Michael Ian Black
obviously does not care about sexual
assault he doesn't seem to care about it
one little bit he's just scoring
political points
had he not said that about louis c.k
then perhaps we could take him seriously
but he's trying to score political
points and there are a lot of people
this happens in politics too when people
try to tell you oh I don't have a
preference here oh no I don't know no
I'm just I'm floating above it all I'm
above it all I'm just you know I'm I'm
self-righteous in this or whatever you
can tell that those guys have a partisan
agenda and they're just not being honest
Ben has said this very well about the
daily wire and CNN people say the daily
wire is right-wing he said yes we have a
point of view but we're open about our
point of view CNN is not open about its
point of view that's why they're fake
news and we're not fake news this is
very important
because demagogues always do this they
always try to say oh I'm floating above
all this how dare you how dare you get
on your high horse but honest people are
gonna deal honestly with you and
president Trump does this very very much
in in his daily politics which is he
doesn't pretend to be something other
than he is he doesn't pretend to have
different goals than he has he doesn't
pretend that his politics are in his
politics he's openly political he is
guilelessly political this is horrifying
to some who have been soaked in this
incompetent mucky culture of Lies and
wail eNOS and it's refreshing to others
who say Oh at least I know where I stand
oh he said he was gonna rip up NAFTA and
then he did oh he said he was gonna
lower taxes and then he did oh he said
he was gonna could I know where I stand
this is a very good thing we have you
know gosh we have so much more to get to
but we're at a time we're out of time
that's too bad because we have I do want
to talk about there's a new study out of
Brown that shows that transgenderism
gender confusion is a social contagion
and this is of course been suppressed by
the PC crowd the so-called party of
science that can't that doesn't like
when science contradicts their own
ideological narratives and there there
are some very important reasons as to
why this is happening in our culture it
dates back to the stay in history which
is when Prince Prince Charles and
Princess Diana got divorced not just
their divorce but divorce broadly I
guess we're just going to have to talk
about it tomorrow how's that for a
cliffhanger huh it's that good because
it's really politically incorrect in
fact I'm you know what we've got to talk
about it tomorrow
so that this episode gets to stay up
then I'll say this it's probably the
least politically correct thing you can
ever say tomorrow and my show will go
canceled but at least we'll have gotten
a good one in the can okay
that's our show get your mailbag
questions in for Thursday in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Nolt show happy national bowtie
day
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jessa alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you
you